[CROWD CHATTER]
KRISTEN RAILEY: Girls who--
ALL: Build.
KRISTEN RAILEY: OK,
that wasn't loud enough.
Let's try it again.
Go ahead and talk.
Ignore me.
[CROWD CHATTER]
Girls who--
ALL: Build.
KRISTEN RAILEY: Awesome.
Good morning, you guys.
My name's Kristen.
You've probably gotten
one or two emails from me.
Thank you all for being here.
The volunteers and I-- they're
wearing these awesome navy
T-shirts-- we're really
excited to teach you
guys engineering concepts
through something
you use every day, cameras.
How many of you guys
have a camera phone?
Raise them higher.
OK.
Mostly everyone.
How about, does
anyone have Instagram?
Snapchat?
Nice.
So I love those things
too, but I am also
an engineer, which is why
I started this program.
Cameras are this
great integration
of all these different
technologies, computer science,
mechanical engineering,
all sorts of things,
and you guys interact
with them every day.
So it looks like you guys
have gotten your hands on them
already and taken them apart.
Did anything surprise
you on what you found?
You can talk to the
people next to you.
[CROWD CHATTER]
Girls who--
ALL: Build.
KRISTEN RAILEY: OK, how
about this group over here.
Did anything surprise you?
AUDIENCE: The tiny, tiny screws.
KRISTEN RAILEY:
Tiny, tiny screws?
How about that
corner in the back?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
compared to the whole camera.
KRISTEN RAILEY: Compared
to the whole camera?
Great.
Anything else, different from
the screws, surprise you guys?
Did anyone have a film camera?
Was there anything
unique about that?
Had you ever used one before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
reusable film cameras, I
was surprised at how
simple they were.
KRISTEN RAILEY: Oh, great.
So you guys are going to learn
a lot about cameras today
and you're even going
to build one yourself.
But before we get
started, I would
like to know, who
comes to mind when
you think of an engineer
or a computer scientist?
So close your eyes
and think about what
this person looks like and what
they do during their day job.
Think about it for a minute.
All right.
Open your eyes.
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
No, they sit at a
computer [INAUDIBLE].
KRISTEN RAILEY: Nice.
How about you in
the green jacket.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Coding and--
KRISTEN RAILEY: What do
they do with the code?
AUDIENCE: Make programs.
KRISTEN RAILEY: Anyone
think of hacking?
Or Mark Zuckerberg?
You guys have probably
seen him before, right?
So those are all
really good examples
of what computer programming is.
Have you guys seen
Iron Man before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KRISTEN RAILEY: So
he does a combination
of computer science and
mechanical engineering,
but engineering is a lot
more broad than that.
And in just camera
technology alone,
here's some interesting examples
that you might not normally
think about.
Have you guys heard of
unmanned aerial vehicles?
Drones?
So a big thing is
putting cameras on them.
And they can do things like
go inside a burning building
and map it out for a fireman.
Another example is
high-speed photography
for understanding
how animals work
or satellite imaging
for figuring out
how healthy the earth is.
And finally, Instagram,
which you guys
have probably heard of.
And like I said before,
camera technology is not just
about computer science.
It involves materials
and mechanics and optics.
And you guys are going
to learn about all
those different components
during this workshop.
So that leads me to what
the goal of today is.
You are going to discover
what camera technology is,
how to apply it, and
gain engineering skills.
And you're going to do this by
building a camera, programming
your own Instagram
filters, and also
learn about applications
of camera technology.
We have an awesome
lineup of speakers,
including space cameras
and medical imaging.
And we have a bunch of
cool demos at the end,
including high-speed
photography, infrared,
and 3D scanning.
So this is just an
overview of today.
We'll begin with a keynote
speaker, Chris Clark,
who I'll introduce in a minute.
And you're going to spend the
first half of the day building
a camera.
You're going to start
off with an introduction
to all the different
components of a camera.
And then you're going
to get your hands on all
the different components, and
assemble them, and program
it to take a picture when
you press the button.
And then during
lunch, we have a panel
from the Society
of Women Engineers,
and the Women's
Technology Program at MIT,
and an all-girls robotics team.
So if you're interested in
a certain part of today,
like, you want to do
more coding or you
want to do more building,
you should pay attention
to these programs.
So they'll talk about what
you can do for longer.
They have summer programs and
programs throughout the year.
And then in the second
half of the day,
we're going to do
image processing.
So you're going to
get an introduction
to how a computer
understands what an image is,
and how you can
manipulate it with math,
and make those really
cool Instagram filters.
And after you program
your own, we'll
have a conclusion and talk
about what you learned.
And finally, we have
those really cool demos
that I mentioned before, where
you'll rotate around and check
them out.
So you all received a picture
of a famous female engineer.
If you didn't get one, I have
a bunch of extras for you guys.
So if you didn't get one, I'm
going to start in the front
and just pass them
down, and take one, OK?
So you guys are going to
be in teams of four today,
and those famous female
engineers and computer
scientists are your teams.
So you're going to work together
on all these challenges,
and the volunteers
will work with you
during those activities.
Now we have some
really boring details,
but they are very important.
So in case of an emergency,
there is stairs in the back.
So when you exit, turn left,
and go all the way to the back,
and then you cluster
outside in the quad area.
And there are bathrooms.
When you go outside, turn
left, and the bathroom
is on your right.
And the volunteers know
where they are too,
if you have any questions.
And you guys are probably
interested in this, where you
can find the photos afterwards.
So I highly encourage you to
take as many photos as possible
with your cameras that
you build and they
will be posted on our
Facebook page afterwards.
It's called Girls Who Build.
And finally, all the
links to the activities
that you do today, and the
code that you worked on,
and the resources,
like, if you want
to build your own
camera at home,
we'll send that to you too.